what about
we're in texas now what about guns
that's the best martial art no but
would you like uh in this crazy time
should people carry guns it's not a bad
idea to have a gun
because if you need a gun you have a gun
and if you don't need a gun
if you're a person with self-control
you're not going to use it you're not
going to just
randomly use it but you have something
to protect you this is the whole idea of
the second amendment
the whole idea of the second amendment
gets distorted by mass shootings or by
terrible people who murder people and do
terrible things but
it's that all those things are real but
they don't take away
from the fundamental efficacy
of having a firearm and defending your
family or defending your life
and there are real live situations where
people have had firearms and it's
protected them
or their loved ones or they've stopped
shooters there's
there's many of these stories but people
don't like those stories because then it
it tends to lead to this gun culture
argument is pro-gun culture argument
that people find very uncomfortable it's
it's human beings are messy
and we're messy in so many different
ways right we're messy
uh emotionally we're messy messy
physically but we're also messy in
what's
good or bad what's we want things to be
binary we want things to be
right or wrong you know one or zero and
they're not
but but there is crime in the world and
there is violence in the world and
you're better off knowing how to fight
and you're betting better off knowing
how to defend yourself
and you're better off having a gun and
yeah i generally think that guns
i do like the idea that guns second
amendment helps protect the first
amendment there's a kind of
sense that makes puts me at ease knowing
that so many people in this country have
guns
that uh i mean alex jones i just
listened to one episode of
infowars for the first time boy is he he
reminds me like when i
drank some tequila i felt like i'm going
to some dark places today
that's how i feel like listening to him
but uh
he talks about like that it's he worries
about martial law
so basically government overreached by
which happened throughout history
like there's there's something to worry
about there but
it's it puts me at ease knowing that so
much of the population
has guns that people government would
think twice
before uh instituting martial law on
cities
but i actually was asking almost like on
the individual level
i maybe shouldn't say this but i don't
yet own a gun
and i felt that if i carry a gun
statistically just for me as a human
knowing my psychology i feel like i'm
more likely to die
like i feel like i would put myself in
situations
that i shouldn't like the way i i will
see the world will change
because my natural feeling is like when
somebody when i was in philly
and i knew late at night in west philly
when some guy looks at you and you can
immediately calculate that this is a
dangerous human being
there it starts with a monkey look at
first like
i'm a bigger monkey than you and that's
where i found like for example i'll do
the beta thing of just looking down and
turning away
and just getting out of trouble like
very politely
and basically that kind of approach
because if you have a in terms of
getting out of serious violence
situations like serious
something where you could die versus if
i had a gun i feel like i would want to
be
that that would be that cowboy monkey
thing where i would want to put myself
in situations
where i'm a little bit of a savior even
of myself
and almost create danger which
can no longer like the escalation of
which
i can no longer control well you're
talking about taking a gun somewhere
versus having a gun in your home
yes yes i mean carry on me that's a
different situation and much harder uh
to get a warrant for or a
license for that you know control uh
concealed carry licenses
especially in massachusetts they don't
come easy a little message yeah that's a
whole nother thing
yeah you're saying gun in the home yeah
a gun in the home
having a gun having knowing how to use a
gun like i know how to use a gun i've
trained you know many hours learning how
to shoot a gun at
tactical places you know there's a bunch
of videos of me
doing it on uh instagram i i practice
and i think it's good to understand how
to be accurate
you